podrían ser cuatro señoras ucranianas
pero son brasileñas y viven en la
pequeña ucrania por eso observan en
redes sociales fotos de mujeres soldados
en el frente dan su apoyo a más de 10
mil kilómetros de distancia
tenemos que luchar desde aquí sólo
podemos luchar con la oración por eso
oremos y tengamos fe en que venceremos
en prudente polis en el sur de brasil
tres cuartas partes de los cincuenta y
dos mil habitantes hablan algo de
ucraniano es el segundo idioma después
del portugués rodrigo michalowski es uno
de los descendientes forma parte de una
hermandad osaka y mantiene costumbres
ucranianas
aunque ya aprendemos a amar a ucrania
desde nuestra infancia abrazamos los
recuerdos y nos aferramos al amor por
esa cultura el resto de nuestras vidas
rápidamente
[Música]
1500 familias ucranianas llegaron a
prudente polis a finales del siglo 19
huían de la pobreza para encontrar un
futuro en las fértiles tierras de brasil
donde acababan de abolir la esclavitud
de las más de 100 iglesias que hay en la
ciudad muchos mantienen el ornamentado
estilo bizantino propio de ucrania pese
a ser brasileños algunos han vivido en
ucrania en el pasado y mantienen lazos
cuatro generaciones después hoy envía un
mensaje a mis amigos diciéndole que si
lo necesitan mi casa está abierta
un mensaje de acogida de estos
brasileños que ven en la huida actual
una historia que igual que para sus
antepasados se repite 100 años después
en un nuevo éxodo para dos ucranianos